situation perdure il ya encore quelques
minutes nous entendions au loin
des explosions des déflagrations en
direction du nord et du nord-est de la
ville qu'elles provenaient du nord de la
ville alors ils pouvoir là comme vous
pouvez le voir autour de moi les
voitures circulent il ya des gens qui se
déplacent mais il s'agit d'un calme qui
est extrêmement trompeurs d'abord nous
sommes ici dans une zone sécurisée ou en
tout cas qui a été très peu frappés par
les par les bombardements de
l'artillerie russe depuis le début du
conflit nous sommes donc au sud de
kharkiv
les gens se sont habitués à cette
situation voilà maintenant cinq semaines
que la ville est soumise à des
bombardements massifs
intensif de la part de la retirer russe
jour et nuit il y à des explosions hier
toute la journée nous avons entendu des
explosions mais pas seulement des
explosions dont tu également entendre un
sifflement extrêmement violent au dessus
de nos têtes en fin d'après-midi il
s'agissait semble-t-il d'un missile
l'envoyer cette fois ci est bien par les
forces d'ukrainiens caf il y a
effectivement et c'est l'information
principale de ces derniers jours des
contre attaques qui d'après les forces
craignent en serait à l'oeuvre au nord
et à l'est de la ville des forces du
craignent n10 avoir repris le contrôle
de deux petites localités sur les sur le
territoire qui était auparavant
contrôlés par les ressorts dans le
centre ville il y a partout des maisons
détruites la situation est extrêmement
grave dans le nord ce sont des villages
et des quartiers entiers qui ont été
quasi rasée par l'arctique russe le
bilan humain évidemment est extrêmement
lourd il y a d'après les autorités
municipales plus de 300 blessés
peut-être beaucoup plus car une certaine
partie de 300 morts excusez-moi civiles
peut-être beaucoup plus car une partie
des victimes n'ont pas encore serait
encore sous les décombres
il ya évidemment des milliers ou de ces
antennes au moins deux blessés et
d'après toujours la municipalité il y
aurait au moins 1500 bâtiment de toutes
sortes y auraient été détruits ou
gravement endommagées par les frappes de
la retirer russes parmi ces 800
bâtiments plus d'une centaine de crèches
et d'écoles romeo bonjour il ya les
civils qui ont pu quitter kharkiv et
ceux qui n'ont pas pu quitter la ville
et à cardiff comme ailleurs en ukraine
le métro est un endroit de est un refuge
oui absolument
lemaitre est devenu un immense dortoir
pour une grande partie des habitants de
la ville alors j'ai pas de chiffres
exacts mais ce qui est certain c'est
qu'ils sont des milliers tous les soirs
18 heures à l'heure où le métro ferme
ses portes métro qui évidemment n'est
pas en activité à gagner donc c'est son
refuge en sous sol afin d'y passer la
nuit à 20 heures il ya un couvre-feu
mais donc dès 18h 19h est bien le maître
commence à se remplir et la population à
l'intérieur s'organise il y à la police
bien sûr d'abord pour assurer l'ordre et
la sécurité et il ya donc des personnes
de toutes sortes beaucoup de personnes
âgées qui ont décidé de ne pas quitter
la ville des familles aussi qui sont là
hier on voit et par exemple des familles
qui regardait des vidéos en streaming
sur l'ordinateur car le métro est
équipée de l'internet il ya évidemment
des sanitaires il ya évidemment des
endroits où prendre des douches enfin
voir il ya toute une vie souterraine qui
se met en place sous donc dans le métro
dans les stations dans de nombreuses
stations de métro de kharkiv kharkiv qui
rappelons le est la seconde ville du
pays qui possède donc des
infrastructures de transport assez
importante
kharkiv avant la guerre compter environ
1.5 million d'habitants il semble que
plus de 30% de la population et quitter
la ville la plupart des personnes qui
ont quitté la ville sont partis donc
pour l'instant en ukraine certains sont
réfugiés à l'étranger mais la plupart
sont encore en ukraine et les personnes
qui sont encore à quartiers sont comme
je disais des personnes âgées pour
beaucoup qui de toute façon n'ont plus
grand chose à perdre ou du moins ce qu
elle considère avec décide de rester ici
là où ils vendent toujours vécu parce
que elles ne veulent pas aller ailleurs
dot qui n'ont pas pu partir et bien tout
simplement car tu n en ont pas les
moyens mais je crois que la majorité de
ces personnes sont des personnes qui
dans décidé comme un acte de résistance
de rester à l'équipe malgré les
bombardements afin d'être en soutien
d'une certaine manière la logistique et
moral aux forces l'ukrainienne qui
combattent tous les jours et c'est donc
une manière de envoyer le message selon
ces personnes qui restent à kharkhiv ce
message selon lequel la ville de tombera
pas